[Musique]
oui
enfin
[Musique]
le combat d'idées c'est son quotidien la
liberté d'expression l'un de ses moteurs
elle est essayiste écrivaine journaliste
réalisatrice par écrit par oral en
images tous les supports sont bons pour
lui permettre de résister aux extrêmes
de droite comme de gauche et ces
dernières années elle a eu de quoi faire
cela a même donné un magazine franc
tireur qui se présente comme un journal
de combat la polémique ça ne lui fait
pas peur les insultes les propos haineux
les menaces même pas peur et pourtant
elle est une cible régulière forcément
quand on donne son point de vue et que
celui ci est prêt si tranchée sans
concession on ne se fait pas que des
amis je disais même pas peur mais après
tout at elle peur parfois pour elle pour
ses proches le combat d'idées est il de
plus en plus dangereux de plus en plus
féroce ou même de plus en plus épuisant
pose en lui toutes ces questions
bienvenue dans un monde un regard bien
jeune et caroline forest merci d'être
avec nous ici au sénat dans ce dom
tournon vous trouvez que le combat
d'idées de plus en plus dur de plus en
plus violents
je je je pense qu'il est dur de plus en
plus pour tout le monde sait qu en fait
moi j'ai commencé un peu de façon
précoce puisque j'ai travaillé sur les
extrêmes depuis maintenant presque plus
de vingt ans donc je me suis vite
habitué j'ai commencé à m'habituer à
cette agora extrêmement extrêmement
agressive aujourd'hui n'importe qui est
victime d' insulte sur les réseaux
sociaux vous tapez casimir c'est quelque
chose que je dis souvent à des gens
quand ils ont passé de cuir par rapport
à ça qu'ils se prennent des polémiques
je leur dis mais taper casimir sur les
réseaux sociaux vous allez voir il se
fait insulter aussi donc c'est à calais
des drames et 6 passes à dédramatiser un
peu ses conseils j'ai donné des
politiques et ça les a beaucoup aidées
par donc on s'y fait voilà on va en vie
avec je parlais de peur quand même
est-ce que c'est vrai qu'il vous arrive
d'avoir peur pour vous pour vos proches
j'ai eu peur pendant la période d
attente a bien sûr c'est une période
très intense support pour mes proches
j'ai eu peur pour mes amis pour beaucoup
de mes amis qui passait sous protection
policière
mais c'est pas le sentiment que j'ai le
plus à combattre chez moi voilà ce jeu
c'est plus dur de combattre la lassitude
à l'épuisement oui oui ça peut arriver
de mener toutes ces batailles mais la
peur c'est plutôt pour les autres je les
trouve moins pour moi ça veut dire que
le combat d'idées c'est quand même du
sacrifice est presque un sacerdoce c'est
comme ça que vous le vivez j'ai un peu
le syndrome du petit soldat ce jeu
personne m'a donné cette mission mais
c'est vrai que je vois bien que de temps
en temps il faut que
j'essaie de me raisonner de plus en plus
en me disant tu es peut-être pas
toujours obligé d'aller de sacrifier en
mode kamikazes et d'aller juste dire ce
dont tu sais que ça va générer une
immense
bronca mai mais en fait je ne sais pas
tellement faire autrement il faut pas se
mentir c'est à dire que je suis
convaincu qu'en fait et plus j'étudie
les débats d'idées plus je me dis qu'en
fait on est beaucoup des tempéraments
avant d'être des conditions ouais et
donc moi je ne sais pas tellement ne pas
dire ce que je pense et je vous le dis
franchement je les ai sentis
effectivement préparant cette émission
est cet entretien avec vous et je pense
que le public va le découvrir au fil de
ce parcours qu'on va retracer avec vous
le magazine que vous avez cofondé
s'appelle franc tireur s'était aussi le
nom d'un journal et d'un mouvement de
résistance à lyon pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale est-ce que vous vous
sentez une résistante est ce que vous
avez l'impression d'être une résistante
aujourd'hui aux idéologies extrêmes du
moment si je me compare aux résistants
de la seconde guerre mondiale évidemment
je me sens très modestement tout à fait
petit et humble mais c'est sûr qu'une
partie de mon engagement vient ma
passion de
travail en tout cas l'énergie que je
mets à essayer de débusquer des masques
et des intégrismes et les extrémismes
vient de cette conscience que rien est
acquis la démocratie n'est pas un acquis
l'égalité est une conquête et que
beaucoup de choses peuvent être remises
en question on voit en ce moment avec
par exemple la question du droit à
l'avortement aux états unis ça fait en
97 j'écris un livre vous me direz que le
droit à l'avortement aux états unis
pourraient tomber un jour donc je pense
que je suis en permanence en alerte pour
essayer de voir d'où vont venir les
coups qui sont les personnages qui
peuvent déjouer des valeurs auxquelles
je tiens qui sont des valeurs très
simple et très modéré liberté égalité
fraternité et laïcité et donc de ce
point de vue oui je me sens en
résistance contre ce qu'ils peuvent
déjouer ses acquis et ses valeurs en
partage franc tireur est présentée de la
manière suivante je cite un journal de
combat combat contre les populismes
combat contre toutes les fièvres
identitaire celle de l'extrême droite
qui maquille la haine d'une religion en
défense de la laïcité celle de l'extrême
gauche qui au nom d'un anti racisme
inversé tree legends selon la couleur de
leur peau on comprend donc il y a deux
ennemis et s'il y en a un qui est plus
difficile à combattre que l'autre je
m'explique je pense à celui de l'extrême
gauche parce que avec des a priori
plutôt positif a priori se disant que
l'extrême gauche c'est forcément plus
humaniste est ce que du coup c'est plus
compliqué de le combattre c'est surtout
plus dur parce que on perd beaucoup plus
d'amis
franchement quand j'ai commencé à
travailler sur les extrêmes évidemment
moi mes premiers combats c'était contre
le front national et ça reste une des je
pense que c'est un des fils rouges de ma
vie me battre pour que le front national
n'est jamais le pouvoir dans ce pays
quel que soit son nom est le membre du
clan
mais disons que c'est un combat qu'il
est plus facile d'assumer à gauche et on
a on a moins de
on a moins de conflits on est moins
culpabiliser et parfois ou attaquer
alors que quand on passe a essayé de
dénoncer effectivement au sein de la
gauche des gens qui ont des
comportements aussi excessifs
essentialisant
très manichéen très sectaire et même
parfois de complicité avec d'autres
intégristes religieux là c'est là que
les coûts ont été les plus dures
évidemment parce qu'on se fait accuser
tous les noms qui surtout on vous
renvoie une image qui n'est pas qui
n'est pas qui vous êtes et il va falloir
il faut vivre avec ça moi j'ai vécu la
transition
quand je travaillais sur christine
boutin au moment de la bataille pour le
pacs et que je dénonçais front national
quand je me suis mise à travailler sur
tariq ramadan en plus du fait que je
m'attaque un intégriste beaucoup plus
dangereux qu'ils avaient des amis
beaucoup plus dangereux j'ai aussi perdu
beaucoup beaucoup de gens de mon camp
nou est vraiment perdu des amis quand
vous dites on se rend vers l'est jamais
quand on combat à l'extrême gauche vous
en avez vraiment perdu oui mais ça
encore une femme je trouve que moi j'ai
pas besoin de beaucoup d'amis donc ça va
aussi avec mon mode de vie mais par
exemple des journaux qui est loué mon
travail ma rigueur comme politis quand
je travaillais sur l'extrême droite du
jour au lendemain se sont mis à
m'attaquer systématiquement et en plus
de fait d'une mauvaise foi incroyable
c'est en attaquant mon honnêteté
intellectuelle en essayant de faire
croire que je n'étais pas rigoureuses
dans votre travail
simplement parce que politis et avait un
compagnonnage intellectuelle avec tariq
ramadan et alors vous avez parlé les
familles le pen que vous ne voulez pas
voir arriver au pouvoir un jour il y
aussi eric zemmour aujourd'hui et puis
marion maréchal qui arrive ça complique
là aussi votre tâche et puis quand vous
voyez un front un rassemblement national
qui obtient plus de 40% vous dites pas
que quelque chose qui va pas dans ce
combat vous l'avez perdu ce combat vous
avez le sentiment d'avoir perdu à j'ai
le sentiment que si on n'avait pas mené
ce combat ça fait très longtemps que la
famille le pen régnerait sur la france
est et en plus j'ai la conviction que le
jour et prennent le pouvoir
contrairement à ce que pensent certains
et le gardon très longtemps donc non
donc vous avez besoin d'avoir presque
gagné et finalement n'ont pas gagné
parce que je veux que vous venez de le
dire on en a encore pour deux
générations peut-être que donc non je
n'ai pas du tout le sentiment d'avoir
gagné ce combat mais j'ai le sentiment
que si on l'avait pas mener encore une
fois ce serait bien pire et gb ces
discussions un jour avec le futur
président tunisien béji caïd essebsi et
qui au début de sa campagne après le
printemps démocratique
me disais mais quand vous avez dit se
poser les questions de s'il devait
attaquer frontalement les islamistes
d'ennahda est dit mais vous vous avez
dédiaboliser front national ça ne vous a
pas réussi je l'avais répondu écoutez
essayé la dédiabolisation vous verrez ça
nous réussit encore moins si vous pensez
que dédiaboliser n'a d'abord réussir à
vous faites une erreur que vous allez
payer très cher et je pense que non on
ne peut pas dé diaboliser le diable en
fait eric zemmour vous l'aviez vu
arriver oui bien sûr c'est difficile pas
d'avoir vu arriver là mais non mais vous
saviez vous qu'un jour quelqu'un qu'on
n'attend pas et qui vient d'ailleurs
pour le coup du milieu de l'audiovisuel
arriverait comme ça sur la scène
politique est comme un de toute façon
partout dans le monde ce n'est pas que
français aujourd'hui et des outsiders
qui naissent partout et c'est la
tendance actuelle profond dont on entend
les gens ont envie parce qu'il ya cette
vague de dégagements donc il faut avoir
une une impression de renouveau alors on
va aller sur l'identité des gens on va
aller sur justement surgir d'un métier
mais griot ont peu à voir trump donc
c'est le coup de soi de l'homme
d'affaires qui passe à la politique soit
du journaliste qu'il passe à la
politique donc c'est mondial ça ne
concerne pas quelque part on a de la
chance parce que encore une fois un
journaliste éditorialiste à peu près
cohérent c'est c'est un métier très
politique c'est un métier très engagé on
n'est pas en train de parler d'un
businessman totalement inculte mais ça
ne veut pas dire qu'il est qu'il en ait
moins dangereux mais alors cette envie
de vous battre pour vos idées contre les
discriminations de tous ordres je crois
qu'elle vous vient très tôt je rappelle
un tout petit peu votre parcours parce
qu'on trouve que c'est intéressant dans
cette émission vous avez grandi à aix en
provence vous y rester jusqu'à
l'adolescence puis vous allez sur paris
à vote avec votre mère pendant votre
cursus scolaire vous allez connaître à
la fois l'école privée catholique mais
aussi le public est là moi je me suis
demandée en disant c'est si l'un de vos
premiers combats qu est l extrême droite
catholique était venue de votre
expérience en établissement privé
catholique ou pas est-ce que ça a été un
moment un peu fort un peu fondateur pour
vous vous avez senti que la différence
c'était difficilement exprimable est ce
que c'est c'est ça qui déclenche votre
premier combat je tiens levée des fois
un soupçon qui vient quand on se défend
ardemment la laïcité contre l'intégrisme
catholique je n'ai pas été violée par un
prêtre n'est pas arrivé d'accord il est
d'ailleurs plus prêtre ni de bonne soeur
à l'époque de l'école où j'étais qui
s'appelait la nativité dû tomber parents
oui
mais j'ai pas été traumatisé par cette
éducation la gt j'ai ressenti
sérieusement l'hypocrisie c'est vraiment
un
c'est une façon d'être qui moi me
méritent toujours beaucoup et j'ai
ressenti l'hypocrisie entre eux un
discours
très moralisateur très moralisateur très
bon
aussi bon prétend que tout est amour
dieu est amour et puis effectivement
j'entendais des discours sur les
homosexuels une violence absolue et
comme j'étais moi même en train de
comprendre je le savais depuis tout
petit mais je l'avais enfouis que
j'étais de ceux en parler en réalité je
pense que ça m'a fait toucher du doigt
oui
déjà ce côté double discours que peuvent
avoir les religieux où les gens très
moraliste en apparence donc ça me vient
sans doute un peu de là et puis j'ai
découvert ma passion pour la laïcité
elle découle de ma passion pour
l'égalité c'est en battant pour
l'égalité des droits que j'identifie qui
s'y opposent le plus c'est les
intégristes religieux sont quand même
souvent sous le chemin en travers de
l'égalité des droits hommes femmes ou
des homosexuels qui m'a amené à la
passion pour la laïcité qui nous protège
tous et puis votre passion ça va être
très vite le journalisme un stage à
france 3 en 94 puis un passage par le
magazine étudiant transferts cpt premier
article et premier gros coup je raconte
un tout petit peu pour le public qui
nous écoutent le rédacteur en chef vous
confie un article sur tabatha cash qui
est une actrice porno connu dans les
années 90 et là vous décrocher un scoop
tabatha cash à une relation amoureuse
avec une figure du milieu skinhead
français serge ayoub alias batskin c'est
ça l'anc est dans la peau c'est c'la
c'est là que ça arrive ben en tout cas
il fallait que je trouve visibles ont un
nombre qui m'intéresse plus que la
commande qui m'avaient été faites pas ce
que je vous avoue que voilà vingt ans
quand votre rédacteur en chef doit être
à bata cache d'abord j'avais évidemment
pas qui c'était
donc lui ça l'amusait beaucoup ça
l'excitait beaucoup comme sujet moi
beaucoup moins et heureusement j'ai
trouvé voilà un angle qui m'a accroché
mais j'ai eu du bol il se trouve que
voilà elle sortait avec batskin et
qu'elle avait un tatouage nazi sur le
saint avec elle avait caché d'une rose
et donc effectivement c'était un peu un
scoop enfin je dis que vous avez glissé
dans la peau parce que dans la foulée je
crois que vous infiltrer une secte
évangélique aussi donc vous avez un goût
incroyable pour l'investigation voir un
feeling quelque chose j'adore ça et j'ai
adoré faire des infiltrations j'en ai
fait pas mal et c'est un des regrets
enfin ça y est j'ai en effet vraiment
assez mais dès que tu devenu un peu plus
connu c'est quelque chose qui les oui je
ne pouvais plus faire mais je me suis
bien amusé arrange qu'est ce que vous
avez fait comme infiltration et j'étais
six mois permanente d'une succursale de
laissez les vivre donc c'est la seule
fois de ma vie que j'ai porté une jupe
même une robe avec un serre tête ou je
me suis fait passer pour une gt engagé
par la permanence de sos futures mères
qui est une branche de laisser les
vivres pour accueillir des femmes
qu'elles aient essayé de dissuader
d'avorter je suis sorti mon infiltration
parce qu'il y avait une jeune femme sans
papiers qu'ils essayaient de détourner
d'envoyer vers des foyers où elle
voulait pas aller donc pour essayer de
l'aider j'ai arrêté mon inspiration
mais voilà j'ai effectivement achèterez
cette secte évangélique qui était d'un
ennui mortel je dois avouer que c'était
ça le plus dur c'est que c'était
terriblement ennuyeux mais le papier que
j'ai réussi à écrire visiblement a fait
un peu mou chez a fait rire des gens
cherchent beaucoup de courriers de
lecteurs et suit m'a le plus touché
c'est un jeune étudiant qui parce que
c'est une secte qui visait
particulièrement les étudiants m'a dit
j'ai beaucoup ri en lisant votre article
et à la fin j'ai compris que j'étais moi
même dans une secte donc je suis allée
voir une association et je suis en train
d'en sortir mais là c'est la plus belle
victoire pour nous a pour une
journaliste syrienne plus beaux
1996 une rencontre majeure fiammetta
venner que vous remarqué pour son
franc-parler face aux anti ivg vous
l'interviewer là c'est le coup de coeur
mais comme tout les deux vous déranger
par une forme de journalisme trop
militant vous fait renvoyer de transe
fac et vous proposer vos propres
enquêtes de manière indépendante jusqu'à
créer la revue prochoix en 97 revue qui
existe toujours je crois en tout cas moi
je suis allé sur le site la ligne
éditoriale se présente ainsi revu
entièrement dédiée à l'enquêté à la
réflexion sur les libertés individuelles
et le droit de choisir et en lisant à
moi je me suis mendicité justement pas
cette revendication des individualités
qui à l'époque avait évidemment plein de
fondement mais dont les conséquences se
font sentir aujourd'hui une
revendication à outrance des individus
et des envies des individualités et qui
nous empêche de faire nation est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous demandez presque si
vous avez bien fait ou pas le mot
pro-choix il vient du mouvement pour
doit se choisir qui s'opposent à
l'intégrisme religieux sur la question
de l'avortement bien ce sera le point de
départ de la revue et effectivement on
s'est retrouvés un carrefour qui cherche
est articulée en permanence liberté
égalité et passionnant
je pense que on a à chaque fois on s'est
posé la question de comment trouver les
meilleurs réglages ça a donné lieu
c'était une revue qui a notamment
beaucoup bataillé en interne en a eu
même un vrai conflit quand eric fassin
des membres de ma revue son parti plutôt
du côté du soutien au voile par exemple
mais alors qu'on était tous d'accord sur
le pacs mais sur le voile on l'était
plus
un disque au fond a écrit dans ma revue
enfin il était stagiaire brièvement à
l'époque elle était laïque elle était
contre le vol brad watts de sandrine
rousseau aujourd'hui bras droit de sang
elle reçoit sur des positions très
différentes donc si vous les ont
beaucoup de gens sont passés par la
revue où nous on a essayé de tenir un
cap qui était une articulation néanmoins
assez citoyenne et c jantes d2 mais
c'est par définition le réglage entre la
liberté d'egalité demande en permanence
en permanence de se poser les questions
de de disputer éventuellement ça c'est
normal donc honnêtement je crois que je
peux relire tous les papiers de pro
choix sans sans aucune honte et après
c'est aussi ça ou le journalisme engagé
apprend à vous remettre en question
c'est que vous êtes connecté au rapport
de force de vote du moment de votre
époque je n'aurais pas exactement je
n'ai jamais d'ailleurs la même position
exactement selon les rapports de force
je garde la vision de ce que je souhaite
pour le monde pour le plus grand nombre
et encore une fois des valeurs simples
dont je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure
mais mais par exemple il ya 25 ans je me
battais pour qu'on parle des
discriminations j'avais des camarades
qui ont expliqué que les avec la lutte
des classes et puis que quand la
révolution arriverez de toute façon tout
ça se serait résolu de soi même et je me
retrouve un an après à me battre plutôt
en dix ans et c'est bien gentil de faire
du clientélisme
communauté par communauté mais s'il ya
plus de projets communs pour lutter
contre les inégalités et si plus
personne ne parle de quand même des
classes sociales honnêtement c'est de la
poudre aux yeux et voyez c'est pour ça
que je vous pose la question parce qu'on
al'impression finalement vous êtes parmi
les précurseurs du combat pour les
particularismes des individualités non
non mais justement je n'ai jamais abattu
pour les particularismes j'ai combattu
contre les discriminations pour
l'égalité au nom de la république et de
ses prêts ses principes mais simplement
il ya 25 ans de fait les dominants ceux
qui étaient les plus bruyants et qui
occupe est clairement le terrain c'était
des gens qui étaient discriminant
et eux mêmes ou sans la gauche bien même
au sein de la gauche aujourd'hui mon
combat c'est pour que la gauche ne
perdent pas de vue que des choses ont
avancé d'abord les lévites aidera à
avancer et que le combat pour l'égalité
ne servent pas faire reculer des
libertés comme la liberté de créer comme
la liberté d'expression parce que ce
sont aussi des valeurs importantes qui
nous ait pas de miss aussi et la
victimisation à outrance je vous pose la
question parce que dans génération
offensé vous écrivez une part non
négligeable de l'hystérie collective
actuelle tient à l'épiderme extrêmement
douillet des nouvelles générations et
plus encore au fait qu'on leur a appris
à se plaindre pour exister les sociétés
contemporaines en place et le statut de
victime tout en haut du podium
aussi même question et pardon ciel vous
dérange un peu mais est-ce que vous êtes
partis aussi d'un combat de plaintes et
donc oui mais sauf cru pardon mais non
mais c'est pas comme ça me dérange pas
mais c'est ça qu'il faut arriver à
expliquer ya pas de position dans
l'absolu c'est tout une question de
degré quand des gens se plaignent
d'avoir été violée je ne sais pas de la
victimisation bien sûr moi j'ai passé 25
ans de ma vie à entendre chaque fois que
je parlais de ce sujet que ce soit mes
soeurs en féminisme qui ont fait le mlf
et qui ont dénoncé la culture deuxième
vingt ans trente ans avant me tous où
que ce soit avec des amis
j'ai pas les trois quarts de mes amis
avaient été violées ou agressées
sexuellement c'est arrivé à peu près
tout le monde donc j'ai passé une
première partie de ma vie à me battre
contre ce silence contre la
culpabilisation des femmes contre la
ronde qui pesait sur elle et c'est vrai
que depuis mis tout l inverse on a
aujourd'hui des cas de
d'hypersensibilité qui dérive en fausse
accusation des gens qui sont annulés du
jour au lendemain sur la base d'une
seule main seul cadre une seule parole
contre parole donc l'injustice n'est
plus au même endroit et en fait si de
deux choses l'une soit vous vous battez
pour des catégories soit vous vous
battez pour la justice si vous battez
pour la justice la ligne elle n'arrête
pas de changer en réalité selon encore
une fois les rapports de fruits on va
continuer d'évoquer votre parcours et
vos combats celui contre les
discriminations crimi nation touchant
les homosexuels on va le faire au
travers d'une archive qui nous a été
transmise par les archives nationales
qui sont nos partenaires sur cette
émission et je vais la lire pour pour en
lire une partie pour le public qui nous
écoutent c'est un appel à manifester du
comité d'urgence anti répression
homosexuels qui date du 4 avril 80 je me
permet de lire ce qui est écrit sur la
condition homosexuelle à l'époque une
loi datant du régime de vichy transférés
dans le code pénal qui interdisait toute
relation homosexuelle avant 18 ans l'om
est ce qui arrange l homosexualité dans
la classification des troubles mentaux
en cas de divorce les parents
homosexuels se voyait le plus souvent
retirer le droit de garde et il existait
au sein de la police un groupe de
contrôle d'homosexuels qui entreprenait
un fichage systématique des homosexuels
on part de très très loin on a fait du
chemin on a fait beaucoup de chemin
selon vous oui mais vous voyez
typiquement en 80 je pense que ceux qui
ont écrit ce texte il n'étaient pas dans
la victimisation c'était d'en dénoncer
des violences des discriminations des
atteintes graves à nos principes
fondamentaux et ils ont eu beaucoup de
coups ils ont eu besoin de beaucoup de
courage pour le faire beaucoup plus
qu'il n'en faut aujourd'hui c'est normal
et c'est très bien et ça fait partie de
la victoire quand je dis que les il ya
un peu d'hyper susceptibilités dans les
jeunes générations c'est que de temps en
temps elle crie très très fort contre
par exemple des micros vexations mais
comme s'il s'agissait de maquereaux
discrimination or c'est pas la même
chose mais je pense que quand on crie
trop fort qu'on n'est pas proportionnée
par rapport à ce qu'ont subi on est
moins efficace moi c'est ma quête c'est
l'efficacité pour qu'on continue à
avancer et même des fois on génère des
retours de bâton donc encore une fois se
plaint des discriminations ou se plaint
de violences et notamment des agressions
sexuelles quand on en est victime c'est
pas de la victimisation c'est quelque
chose absolument nécessaire ensuite
crié très fort parce que quelqu'un eut
un propos maladroits on n'a pas employé
le bon prenons pas ce qu'il connaît pas
exactement où est ce qu'on en est de sa
transition c'est ces contre-performances
et des degrés quoi exactement parmi vos
combats vous il ya eu le pack soul avait
un petit peu dit pacte civil de
solidarité et vous est alors journaliste
pour têtu magazine et président du
centre gay lesbien vous faites votre
première télé dans l'émission public de
michel field vous nous raconter
l'anecdote où je le fais ça a été un
moment fort de télévision vous êtes en
plateau enfin pas en plateau vous êtes
dans le public et michel pinton qui est
maire d'une commune de la creuse qui a
lancé une pétition contre le projet de
loi du pacs et il affirme que les
homosexuels n'ont pas à pouvoir s'unir
puisqu'ils ne peuvent pas faire d'enfant
vous souvenez de ce que lui et bien sûr
je pense que j'ai fait rire ce qui
n'était pas évident parce que faut se
représenter qu'à l'époque des lesbiennes
qui apparaissent à la télé je n'ai
vraiment pas beaucoup moi même je n'en
ai pas vu beaucoup avant d'y apparaître
j'ai les cheveux très courts
et donc je vraiment je dénote si vous
voulez donc il faut prendre la parole il
faut affronter ce regard là qui est un
regard un peu exotique un peu
déshumanisant il faut arriver à le
dépasser à rester calmes et en plus pour
essayer de convaincre dans une bataille
où quand même on n'avait pas encore
obtenu la majorité des coeurs et des
reins sur cette question l'égalité il
faut répliquer à quelqu'un qui est quand
même mère qui est quelqu'un d'état be et
qui vient de dire cette phrase qui pour
moi est d'une violence absolue bahia les
unions en fait qu'on laisse pas trait à
la mairie puis il ya ceux qui vont salir
les murs parce qu'ils sont non
reproductif et donc je vais juste
répliqué que je voulais rappeler qu'il y
avait quand même des couples
hétérosexuels qui était stérile ça
arrive et que donc on si c'était le
critère en fait comment on allait faire
pour être bien sûr de triel entraide et
mary est ce qu'on allait installer des
détecteurs de fécondité ça pouvait être
intéressant ça allait être compliqué et
du coup tout le monde a un peu sourit
serre ap en fait j'ai essayé de les
renvoyer à l'absurdité de la règle qui
était une règle de normes et pas une
règle de droit en réalité le juste et ça
a permis peut être un peu décoincé
certains certains dans leur presque
c'est à ce moment là que vous rendez
compte aussi de l'impact médiatique de
la télévision et que vous prenez goût
peut-être aux apparitions télé parce que
vous rendez compte que ça peut marcher
dans le militantisme en tout cas c'est
certain que ses interventions dans ces
années la survie du pacs qui sont des
années ou quand vous apparaissez vous
devez à la fois de normaliser la vision
que les gens ont des homosexuels vous
devez calmer leur peur et en même temps
vous devez les convaincre arriver à les
faire bouger un peu c'est des années où
le pouvoir de huy la télévision est
extrêmement fort je le vois je vois les
préjugés qui recule je vois des gens qui
vont mieux jouer des homosexuels qui
sont plus protégés par ses apparitions
accessoirement à l'époque quand je passe
dans l'ajout de l'assemblée général
d'act up j'ai évidemment je suis
applaudi à prémesques massage télé donc
c'est des moments très très ouais c'est
des moments fort bien sûr il ya eu
d'autres vont d'un fort je pense à ceux
aussi face à tariq ramadan alors moi je
me suis toujours visionner en mai sur le
plateau de campus présenté par guillaume
durand puis dans l'émission de frédéric
taddeï et là vous démasquer quasi en
direct devant tout le monde sur ce
plateau le double discours de cet homme
devant des millions peut-être de
téléspectateurs à ce moment là c'est
vraiment une victoire dans votre vie
d'enquêtrice parce qu'il a été persona
non grata après ça oui enfin ça a été
honnêtement la sépaq émission de
télévision parce que ça a été dix ans de
travail très gros match et disant très
long très c'est vraiment et ça a été un
combat très très très difficile la
première fois que je le croise
effectivement personne ne lui a encore
tenu tête pas même nicolas sarkozy à la
télévision et laisser un peu de
m'intimider moment des sujets il me fait
un regard un peu dégoûtant honnêtement
un peu sexuelle un peu dégoûtant
s'aperçoit qu'il n'est pas tombé sur la
bonne personne et puis je lui porte un
premier coup parce que je suis venu avec
deux fait des extraits de ces cassettes
qui contredisent totalement ça on entend
l'enregistrement sa communication donc
il est un peu d'effet mais bon c'est moi
j'ai trois secondes au milieu d'un
plateau on est 6 on n'est pas dans une
idée on n'entend pas très bien
l'enregistrement est en plus voilà c'est
pas comme si on le voit juste un peu
vacillé mais c'est tout la réalité c'est
qu'à ce moment là une partie de la
gauche est en train notamment le
mouvement altermondialiste est en train
de tisser des alliances avec lui et à
travers lui avec les frères musulmans
tout le monde se demande si les
modernistes si les fondamentalistes et
personne n'a la réponse est et moi on me
dit notamment grâce et mon éditeur m'a
dit mais tu veux pas prendre le temps
d'aller une fois bonne fois pour tout
faire ce que tu as commencé à faire
comme travail
et trouver la réponse est je sais
d'ailleurs je leur ai dit je les dis à
mon éditeur christophe bataille jeudi là
tu me demande de signer pour l'enfer en
fait je crois que c'était pire que ce
que j'avais envie que c'était bien pire
c'était dix ans d'enfer parce que parce
que les frères musulmans sont retardés
les mouvements les plus stratèges et les
plus machiavéliques sur lesquels j'ai eu
à travailler parce qu'ils sont très
nombreux parce qu'ils ont beaucoup
d'alliés parce qu'ils sont capables de
tous les coûts de tous les mensonges de
toutes les vraiment de tout donc ça a
été très dur est l'aboutissement c'était
peut-être un peu ce duel chez frédéric
taddeï ou là pendant une heure on a été
face à face
mais mais mais ça n'a pas suffi une
seule fois dire que moi je le connais
sans parker fut peut-être une des scènes
qui peut démonter sa mécanique quelques
auprès du grand public quand même auprès
du grand public s'était déjà les faire
calmement il fallait poliment en effet
clan justement ces huit ans très dur
passé à travailler sur ce personnage ce
que je crois savoir faire mais il y aura
toujours une partie du public qui
préférera être sous le charme de l'un ou
de l'autre mais je voudrais être pas
dans la réflexion plutôt que dans les
seuils de 10 porteurs est léger des
photos pour vous caroline fourest
alors des photos qui sont censés vous
parlez je suis sûr que celle-ci vous
parlera enfin test lima nasreen femme de
lettres bangladaise et pakistanaises une
femme de combat elle aussi avec laquelle
vous avez écrit un livre publié en 2010
libre de le dire elle lutte ce au péril
de sa vie pour la liberté des femmes
contre l'obscurantisme religieux est ce
que votre vie de militante
c'est aussi construite grâce à ce genre
de rencontre à des rencontres
et vous me disiez tout à l'heure il faut
du courage pour voilà pour prendre les
positions que vous tenez
moi ces personnages gens fréquentent
allemand et j'ai quand même la chance
d'être entouré de gens qui ont vraiment
besoin de courage et beaucoup plus que
moi parce que on vit en france on vit
dans un très beau pays honnêtement et et
même quand les coups sont durs ça reste
des coûts dans une démocratie tant qu'on
reste une démocratie ça reste un pays de
d'enfants gâtés autour de moi il ya des
gens comme taslima nasreen j'ai eu la
chance aussi de l'échangé avec salman
rushdie j'ai rencontré beaucoup de gens
dans ma vie qui réellement risquent leur
peau tout le temps et qui en plus cela
risque dans des contextes où ils n'ont
pas beaucoup de temps pour souffler pas
beaucoup de protection ils sont pas
protégés par l'état ils sont pas là il
n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de
respiration au milieu de la guerre et
donc ça me ramène moi toujours justement
aussi assez de modestie de me dire je
suis quand même très chanceuse et une
photo moins lourdes ou moins graves
louis de funès alors vous vous comprenez
mais public peut-être ne comprend pas
que femme de louis de funès et vous
étiez fan de comédies vous aviez envie
d'être comique jamais j'ai toujours pas
renoncer à faire des comédies vous
verrez cet intérêt sérieusement non mais
je moi je suis persuadé que c'est mon
grand père louis de funès alors
évidemment ça ne se voit pas mais mais
c'est quand il est mort j'ai cru que mon
grand père était mort j'avais 8 ans je
crois ce qui est fou parce qu on vous
connaît sur des sujets lourds grave dans
une forme de solennité et j'ai tendance
à dire que j'ai un peu grippé dans ma
carrière voyez pas ce que c'était plutôt
ça au départ j'ai fait ce qu'il m'a dit
c'est qu'est ce qui s'est passé ce que
je voudrais pas c'est l'adversité
l'extrême droite les intégristes
religieux et c'est passé tout ça sinon
moi c'était plutôt ce métier qui
m'intéressait et j'aurais pas eu le
jenny d'être évidemment louis de funès
mais de travailler avec des monstres
comme ça de comédie je pense que c'est
sincèrement le rien de plus fort que de
faire rire les gens rien plus fort c'est
la chose la plus extraordinaire au monde
c'est aussi ce que j'ai tellement aimé
dans l'aventuré charlie travail des
dessinateurs qui avaient ce pouvoir là
ce talent là
il ya rien de mieux que ça alors votre
prochain film une comédie ou pas j'ai
déjà écrit une comédie mais honnêtement
je dois un peu changé mon image avant
d'arriver on fasse confiance pour faire
vrai midi un appel au producteur
audacieux j'ai les producteurs j'ai ce
qu'il faut mais j'ai des bords un
deuxième film a posé la bande à l'est
mais c'est en route mais on va y aller
par étapes on en entend rarement de
votre part oui mais on est en france
voyez le doucement attendait le dit pas
trop une dernière question en lien avec
ce lieu dans lequel nous sommes caroline
forest on est entouré de quatre statues
qui représentent chacune une vertu la
sagesse la prudence la justice et
l'éloquence là comme ça spontanément s
qui en a une qui vous parle plus que les
autres sagesse prudence justice
éloquence comme ça instinctivement oui
c'est dur de choisir à j'ai quand même
envie de vous dire l'éloquence au
service de la justice je peux comprendre
au moins deux bombes est très bien c'est
votre réponse merci merci en tout cas
d'avoir été avec nous aujourd'hui dans
ce dom tournons dans un monde un regard
merci nous a fait partager votre regard
sur le monde est un peu de votre monde
merci à vous de nous avoir suivi et à
très bientôt sur public sénat
[Musique]